la violencia que se ha encendido en
diversas regiones del Perú el llamado a
la insurgencia por parte de
simpatizantes el expresidente Pedro
Castillo la violencia desatada en las
manifestaciones de las últimas horas que
ha producido dos muertos han obligado a
la presidenta Dina boluarte a recortar
su mandato y atender la principal
demanda de las protestas que es el
adelanto de las elecciones es por eso
que la presidenta de los peruanos espera
llegar a un acuerdo con el parlamento de
este país para adelantar las elecciones
abril de 2024 justamente Perú vive un
clima inestabilidad social en estos
momentos con convocatorias a paros
nacionales y también toma de entidades
públicas Por esa razón Dina boluarte ha
declarado el estado de emergencia para
que retorne la tranquilidad y le ha
ordenado a las fuerzas de seguridad
respetar los derechos humanos de los
manifestantes